the 2022 world's billionaires list is a
list of all the billionaires that we can
find in the world everybody worth one
billion or more
altogether this year we found
2668 billionaires and of that
327 are women and of those women 101
have self-made fortunes so that means
that they were a founder of a company or
a co-founder or in the case of like
cheryl sandberg they were hired to work
at facebook and they have enough stock
facebook that their billionaire from
that
and by self-made we don't mean
everything themselves we use self-made
to indicate that
they either started a company themselves
or with a co-founder or worked at a
company we're hired onto a company as
opposed to inheriting a fortune
we've got a really interesting mix of
companies that these women have
founded and are growing
it ranges from
cosmetics
to
food to data centers
finance to a company called canva which
maybe people know from using their
products for creating stuff online
perhaps the best known of course is
rihanna
who's of course known for her music but
she's on the list because of her
business savvy and her co-founding of
fenty beauty which is a cosmetics empire
with lvnh the luxury goods company of
france she's worth about 1.7 billion
dollars
this year there are 11 new self-made
women on the list
some of the most notable are falguni
nayar of india she's worth 4.5 billion
dollars she's a former banker who quit a
decade ago and decided to open a online
beauty retailer and then they also open
retail shops as well and they sell 4 000
brands
online
mostly in india um they've got 100 or
more shops and they do fashion and
beauty melanie perkins of australia is
an another notable newcomer she's a
co-founder of a company called canva
which helps you create cool looking
stuff for
invitations graphics for online
she's worth 6.5 billion dollars
another newcomer is miranda q of china
she co-founded an e-commerce and social
media company
that translates as little red book
and it focuses on selling goods that are
from outside of china she's worth 1.8
billion
the newcomers range from
you know a mix of tech beauty retailers
you know e-commerce that kind of stuff
and then of the women who've been on the
list for a while i mean we've got a
roofing billionaire diane hendricks in
the united states she co-founded a
roofing supplies company
um got tom and judy love together they
founded loves truck stops
in recent years the number of
billionaires has been increasing each
year this year we had the most drop-offs
for our list since the financial crisis
in 2009.
even though we have new self-made women
the net number of supplement dropped
from 108 last year to 100 this year
in the united states and globally we had
a downtrend in stock prices and so that
led to
more of these drop-offs
investors have gotten sick of
unprofitable companies and they've been
moving to dump the shares the values of
their holdings have dropped as a result
forbes found more billionaires in the
united states
than in china
and yet of the of the self-made women
the opposite is true 45 are from china
followed by 25 from the united states
which is pretty interesting because um
you know china's
traditionally a communist country right
they have all these billionaires right
so there's capitalism with a twist
that's going on there lots of companies
have gotten onto the stock market
one of the things that we're seeing even
though women are still a minority
on the list um in terms of you know so
far more men are billionaires than women
and
far more men
are founders or co-founders of companies
than women are i think the trend is
moving toward where we're seeing more
women create companies it's slow right i
mean part of the problem and this has
been an issue that's been discussed
particularly in silicon valley with
venture capital funding is how little
venture capital funding has gone to
companies founded by women
forbes has written about how there's a
movement to change this called all raise
more and more women in venture capital
looking to fund companies
that are founded or co-founded by women
so i think it's a matter of time where
we'll eventually see more women
billionaires especially self-made
billionaires on this list
[Music]